okay so there's a bit more news about
the expanse and this news is if true
really quite shocking
pretty amazing actually
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so about a week ago i did a video
telling you guys how um the producers
and creators of the expanse
were locked away in a room and they were
working on a big project that was
hopefully going to be getting started
quite soon and that project according to
my sources
was a spin-off series something that
would fill the gap between book six and
book seven that 30-year space that we
have and that it would be
related to the original expanse story it
would be an offshoot of several of the
things they kept talking about in series
six that they never really resolved
and that it would have some but not all
of the original cast in it now
i have spoken to somebody else who has
said actually
these guys are locked away in a room but
it is not to do the project you think it
is
so what have i been told i'm going to
read the message do you directly i'm not
going to tell you who the source is i'm
sorry that's not fair i can tell you
that it is a subscriber and i can also
tell they have told me where this
information came from and the person the
original source is very close to the
expanse
i've not spoken to them personally so i
am taking this with a pinch of salt no
disrespect to the source or the um the
subscribers told me this but if i
haven't been told it directly i can only
give it so much weight but i'll tell you
what i think about the news at the end
of the video
so
um i've popped up a notice for the vid
on the 18th about the expanse series
seven this is what i know six episodes
one hour 30 minutes each full original
cast unlike book 7 which was supposed to
be 30 years later it's now set just
three years after the book six
filming supposedly start in late
september or early october to air just
before christmas thursday 22nd december
22nd um amazon prime books eight and
nine will be filmed next year it would
be interesting to see if this
information close to what i know maybe
talking about the video i've just talked
about what he is very clearly saying is
that there's not going to be a spin-off
series of the expanse but in fact they
are going to make series seven
series seven will be based on book seven
but it will only be three years after
the book six instead of the three
decades he goes on to say that dominique
tipper and frankie adams have been in
italy for a couple of weeks talking
about and reading through the script
uh the spin-off about mars and the mars
av and the marines he talks about
um right last year phil moon was six was
only officially announced in
mid-november um but he says the filming
started within a couple of weeks so the
positive announcement so he doesn't seem
to think that it being a secret is um a
big problem
um
he goes on to tell me that the expanse
viewing figures have actually been much
higher than expected and they're really
really happy with them they're talking
about 64 million viewers you don't
actually generally know if that's the
same people watching it over and over
again but if that's like 64 million
views
um on average per episode that's doing
pretty damn well
um
so
this also goes into what i'm saying
about the expanse is that it doesn't
really matter the viewing figures as
much as there is a very loyal fan base
and if that fan base will stay with
amazon for a new series of the expanse
they'll 100 do it you also have to
remember that jeff bezos himself is
actually an expanse fan
and he would 100 want to bring
this back
so what do i think about this news
if it's true and again pinch of salt
um
it kind of makes sense to me in that
amazon are really really secretive and
they always have been and they do like
to put misinformation out there so the
information i'm getting about
potentially a spin-off series might be
that it might just be rumors that are
going around and really they want to
bring back um series seven i think they
would want to bring back zero seven
ideally this gap between book six and
book seven this thirty year gap is
confusing and only the real fans of the
series would understand it they would
understand what the hell was going on
casual viewers would have no clue why
there's a third three decade gap and why
everyone looks the same
so i think it makes sense that they
might re-jig the books and rejig the
story to fit a more believable time
frame so this three-year gap between
book six and book seven makes sense i
don't think there's anything major in
the storyline that again they couldn't
rejig for the series for it to make
sense
this hour and a half six episodes detail
that he's thrown in
i would find that to be unusual
because that would actually be the same
as doing sort of nine
one-hour episodes or something like a
normal run
so i don't really understand that but
if the producers have said
the way the episodes break up fits into
six episodes of an hour and a half
better
that's the nice thing about streaming
services that actually the producers get
to do whatever they want within reason
if they want to do one episode there's
45 minutes an episode there's an hour
and a half and an episode that's through
they can it doesn't matter if they want
to do five episodes 12 episodes it
doesn't really matter from a production
cost point of view it'll cost roughly
what it normally costs to produce a 10
episode series they'll just release it
in six episodes so
yeah
that that's perfectly reasonable if
that's what the producers want to do
so do i think this is true
well this subscriber has been a loyal
subscriber for pretty much the full
existence of psytrek um i've spoken to
them many times before i don't think he
would actively lie to me and he says he
has spoken to like i say someone very
close to the expanse personally so
i i think it could be it's at very least
he believes it's true um the like i say
amazon are very secretive and they like
to throw out lots of random information
but
at the same time when expanded season
six ended they said the producers actors
they all said this isn't the end we're
going on a bit of a break
this is not the end of the series um a
couple of the actors have come out after
a couple of quite cryptic messages
saying basically you know wait and see
something might be happening so 100
think this could be true the nice thing
about this rumor is we're not gonna have
to wait very long to find out
and we're literally talking six to eight
weeks according to sources when it
started filming there is no way once
filming starts they would keep it secret
so
let's see what happens
there are a couple of issues with this
though that i do have
one
the expanses never met the viewing
figures they hoped amazon have never
ever quite managed to push this
franchise in the direction they wanted
it to it doesn't get the viewing figures
it has a very small but very loyal fan
base
um that's why i could kind of see a
spin-off series working
and then to run into series 7 because
you could try to draw some new fans in
on the flip side of that the small but
very very loyal fan base would be
desperate to see this and would be very
very happy and i actually think jeff
bezos would be happy and at the end of
the day he's the guy writing the checks
so
do i believe it
it's definite maybe i'm going to say 50
50 on my side um but as i say we'll find
it really soon
so what do you think get into the
comments tell me what you think about
this rumor do you think it's even
remotely possible or do you think it's
just more of that amazon smoke
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification really helps us out and if
you are a regular sidetracker please
consider hitting the join button and
really supporting the channel
as always please stay safe and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you